[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vive la soupe à l'oignon auront pour
voir les enfants vivent leur soupe à
l'oignon
comme vous le voyez notre nounours est
très optimiste j'ai faim patrons aussi
je fais mon marché et je vais me
préparer une de ces petites sous gratiné
rose à nyon hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
égale trois mois
mais là je crois que ça fait d un puce
rhin et galt eu des enfants ce soir je
vais vous préparez une de ces soupes à
l'oignon vous m'en direz des nouvelles
on va s'amuser alors d'accompagner
cuisinier la merci et préparer moi mon
chapeau de cuisine eu des ratés des
monts et novara non ma recette est un
secret de grand chef je préfère
travailler dans le secret vous allez à
vos opérations
que de mon chapeau 2 serait
merci nicolas à présent j'ai tout ce
qu'il me faut mais à nyon trop et mon
chapeau je vous appellerai quand j'aurai
terminé à lui
les cuisiniers tu sais c'est toujours
comme ça retournez à vos calculs étroits
l'ours adet fourneaux
[Musique]
pour
leur présence et plus chez les ayew
avant de les faire revenir
bon
alors nicolas de plus combien ça fait
c'est trop difficile si on allait voir
ce que le grand chef prépare sans faire
de bruit le noble
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il y
ait un gros chagrin mais maladroit il
s'est sûrement brûler votre console et
howie grand chef faut pas rater chagra
sa mère servi dos au
[Musique]
but
la
même masse par chance il est oublié nous
voilà
c'était un grand chanteur n'ont su que
les oignons mycéniens ont lésé plus jean
gilles me piquer les yeux je ne pouvais
plus m'arrêter
[Rires]
pognon alors j'ai fini je n'en veux plus
alors
ce que j'ai fait
tu as bien raison ces vues lasagnes ans
qui font pleurer notre nom nous on ne
fait jamais plus à rennes c'est vrai
bonne nuit les enfants la prochaine fois
je vous ferai un potage velouté aux
fines herbes
dormi vite
se conjuguent for
many noces
[Musique]
alors nounours tu t'es bien régalé non
je meurs de faim pas trop ces vilains
oignons m'ont fait pleurer je n'ai pas
pu faire masse ou gros nigaud les
oignons il pique toujours les yeux oui
oh la la ce que j'ai phares on s'en va
en route bonne nuit les enfants fêtes de
bourg
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]